your doctor will perform surgical
debridement to remove dead tissue from
in and around your wound
wounds can result from a variety of
causes including injuries burns bed
sores also called pressure ulcers or
decubitus ulcers and infected surgical
incisions
dead damaged or contaminated tissue can
compromise circulation to your wound in
addition the unhealthy tissues are prone
to infection
dead tissues invite bacteria to grow
which compete with growing cells for
nutrients and interfere with the healing
process
the wounds healthy tissues may become
infected
the infection may develop into a pocket
of pus called an abscess that impedes
wound healing
a wound resulting from a burn may form a
hardened crust of dead tissue called an
S car that can prevent healthy tissue
growth and healing
before your procedure your doctor will
numb the area around your wound with
local anesthetic for more extensive
debridement you will receive general
anesthesia
to begin your doctor may use saline or
disinfectant solutions to wash or
irrigate your wound
next your doctor will evaluate the depth
of your wound
checking the extent of the dead tissue
your doctor may remove a rim of tissues
from around your wound to create a clean
margin of healthy tissue
and improve healing
at the end of your procedure your doctor
will place a dry bandage in your wound
to manage any bleeding he or she may
also cover your wound with moist
dressings to encourage healing
after your procedure you should follow
wound care directions very carefully be
sure that you protect your wound from
injury and keep the wound and its
dressings clean and dry